we have another visitor from your earth
meet dr. Harrison wells from earth-2
all right hi I'm guessing you didn't
travel between dimensions just to meet
the flash that's exactly what I did
someone's infected my world now he's
coming for yours now ready to fight soon
you're the sprayer flash do your job
putting above everything
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash trailer breakdown so big
thing is is this is gonna be a zoom in a
dr. light episode but not the dr. light
you were expecting and real quick
reminders the reverse flash ring
giveaway for this week is still going on
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video the episode is titled darkness and
light so of course it's gonna be the
doctor light episode you see her use her
powers here I'm assuming they're gonna
be a slightly tuned down version of what
they are in the comics her powers
defined as photo Kinesis and she
actually the interesting thing about how
she got her powers in the comics is that
during crisis on Infinite Earths as they
were nearing the final battle the
monitor wanted to raise a new champion
to help fight the anti-monitor
so he basically uses his powers to
activate her as a new champion of Earth
most you're probably familiar with our
third light the crazy scientist that
cisco mentioned on season 2 of arrow
that was that was actually a long time
ago now they used his light gun he has
some gear hidden in the basement of STAR
Labs but the really cool thing that the
TV show is changing about the character
is that it's going to be the earth 2
version of Linda Park isn't that crazy
that's freakin awesome we also learn in
the trailer that Harrison wells is
responsible for creating zoom either
metaphorically or through an accident or
through his version of the particle
accelerator explosion so right off the
bat he's not zoom and I don't think most
of us thought that he was either
I think the likely candidates are some
of the good characters now some of the
good speedsters that he says this really
important thing about zoom poisoning his
earth he's gonna do the same thing to
your earth so it sounds like earth 2 is
kind of like a crime syndicate earth we
know zoom has been throwing metas at
Barry trying to get rid of him so that
he's the only speedster left so that no
one's left to challenge him so either
all these evil earth two characters are
compelled to fight for him or they're in
league with him I think what's going on
is that they're just more afraid of zoom
than they are of everyone else so
they'll just do whatever he says
that's what I think Harrison wells is
talking about when he said zoom poisoned
his earth and that he's bent all the
medes to his will like either you can
serve me or you can die so that really
does sound like crime syndicate which is
actually earth 3 in the the DC
multiverse but remember this is the TV
universe this is earth 2 as far as I can
tell though us seeing earth to Linda
Park
as dr. light is our first instance of
seeing an evil version of an earth one
character like we haven't seen any of
these main characters evil twins from
Earth 2 yet if they if they are evil I'm
assuming that some of them are probably
still good it's just that the writers
are using earth to to surface most of
the new villains now I've already done a
dr. light video for the flash whenever
they announced that they were gonna
bring her on the show so I'll put a link
for that in the description but the
comic book version of the character's
name is kimi o hoshi so she actually at
a certain point in the comics she ends
up having to battle it out with arthur
light he's like how dare you take my
mantle so hopefully in a future season
we'll get to see like evil earth to
linda park dr. light
battle it out with arthur light from
earth one as much as people complain
when things get changed from the comics
i feel like this is going to be really
awesome this take on the character just
getting a chance to see one of the
characters that we love be evil is way
more fun than doing arthur light plus if
you're familiar with the arthur like
character you know how he's kind of
problematic he is one of the worst human
beings in the multiverse but just to
talk a little bit more about zoom now
that we've seen his costume like in a
much more close-up way it looks like the
black racer suit now the black racer is
two different characters there's the
black costume flash which is just like
kind of an aspect of death for
speedsters and then there's the new gods
version of the black racer which is a
different character now if you've been
reading Geoff Johns Darkseid war right
now it's his Justice League title that
he's writing right now it's actually
really badass so you should check it out
but he actually combined the Barry Allen
flash with the New Gods version of the
black racer to create a new gods black
flash and it looks an awful lot like
zoom on the TV show so just theory craft
as you will I don't think that that's
what the TV show is doing I mean it's
not gonna be the new gods but it just
it's really interesting the imagery this
evokes really I think the biggest reason
that they chose the black costume and
the blue lightning is to differentiate
zoom from Professor zoom a or Bart
thought last season just because there's
still people that I see in the comments
who are confused about the difference
between zoom and professor zoom there
are two different characters that are
part of the reverse-flash family so you
have the flash family any of the
reverse-flash family although i don't
think the reverse flashes would think of
themselves as family but the TV show
never actually called a Oh Bart Thawne
professor zoom last year so I think a
lot
TV show only people are a little
confused about that don't worry whenever
we're talking about zoom we're talking
about this black costume zoom but just
to run down the list of possibilities I
feel like it's still growing like it
could still be a number of characters
right now the most interesting would be
John Wesley Shipp would be Barry's dad
if he were the reverse-flash that'd be
like a twisted version of Thomas Wayne
from flashpoint
where by Bruce Wayne died as a child so
Thomas Wayne his father became Batman
but he's this evil crazy version of
Batman there's earth to Wally West even
more interesting than that would be Joe
West or iris West that'd be crazy if
iris West was oom I don't think she is
then you have evil version of Barry
which i think is a little too obvious
you have evil version of patty which is
a little bit more likely a little bit
more interesting and then you have the
edward clariss reverse-flash who was the
reverse flash during jay garrick's time
in the comics during the Golden Age as
much as this is a show about Barry
Allen's journey in all the other
characters are just passing through it I
do think that they're gonna do more Jay
Garrick era stuff if you're gonna bring
Jay Garrick on the show you might as
well bring some of his characters along
for the ride too so given that we know
Tony Todd is doing the voice and then
the way that zoom talks that we've heard
him talk who do you think this character
is I still think that it's a male
character and I'm slowly drifting away
from it being Barry just because Barry
doesn't talk with that inflection even
if you were being evil he wouldn't talk
like that just the way his accent works
remember they're going for the Darth
Vader thing where you have a different
actor doing the voice in the scary
costume but you don't know who's
underneath and if you ever wanted the
best deconstruction of why it's a bad
thing that there's a white actor
underneath the black costume just watch
like the first five minutes of chasing
Amy it there's like the greatest
deconstruction of Star Wars ever and
that is just the first 10 minutes of
that movie Episode seven is gonna be
when Gorilla Grodd comes back the title
of the episode is guerrilla warfare so
it's gonna be awesome he kidnaps Caitlin
Barry has to track him down and Cisco is
supposed to be going on a date with
Hawkgirl so I can only imagine how
that's gonna end once Hawkman finds out
about it in the description for the
episode it also says that patty is
getting suspicious that Barry is hiding
something from her so she still has not
found out that Barry is the flash as of
episode 7 so get hyped because it is
going to be
bananas so what's gonna happen next is
is dr. who's gonna be tomorrow morning
I'll post that video then I'll do an
arrow trailer video for Constantine
that's when I'll do the QA and the
reverse flash ring giveaway so while you
guys wait for all that you can click
here to watch my Supergirl trailer video
but almost more people watch Supergirl
on Monday night than watch The Walking
Dead on Sunday night just to give you an
idea and you can click here for this
week's flash episode thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight